marceau bonsoir alors 86 n'a pas été une
année facile tout de même pour air
france parce que vous avez annoncé un
bilan bénéficiaire mais le chiffre
d'affaires lui a plutôt baissé
bastien de chiffre d'affaires a baissé
c'est d'ailleurs normal puisque le
dollar baisser c'est une monnaie qui
compte beaucoup dans l'aviation et le
chiffre d'affaires effectivement était
de 27 milliards cette montre presque 30
la déplacer il a baissé donc à peu près
huit et demi pour cent dont 5 % sont
dues aux changes monétaires hausse du
yen baisse de la livre ce du marque et
c'est donc ce qu'il faut retenir de ce
si c'est qu'effectivement le trafic
passagers a baissé de trois et demi mais
le trafic fret a augmenté de plus de 10
de 11 % répondent nous transportons en
kilos plus de frais que deux passagers
alors comment à 70% sur des pays
étrangers
alors pour 87 vous achetez c'est nouveau
à leur gardien c'est une statine de
votre ambition c'est un signe de notre
ambition mais d'une ambition durable car
nous venons les décisions étaient prises
pour renouveler notre flotte moyen
courrier nous disent on est 150e place
ceci c'est l'achat des airbus 320 que
nous recevons de 88 à 92 et 17 vague
d'achats terminée nous renouvelons notre
flotte long courrier à partir de 1992 en
cinq ans de 92 à 96 par l'achat de 16
boeing 747-400 alors 1,87 est ce qu'il y
aura aussi parce que 86 vous avez fait
des efforts pour présenter de nouvelles
opportunités aux passagers et ses 187 il
y aura aussi très concrètement pour les
opérations absolument absolument car
pour l'année 87 d'abord nous ouvrons
vingt nouvelles escales et 20 nouvelles
lignes 13 au départ de paris sept au
départ de province
l'essentiel est destiné à maillé
l'europe de manière à ce que nous soyons
bien placé sur le tissu européen lors de
la réalisation du marché intérieur est
unique en 1992 nous sommes déjà très
bien installés mais le seront encore
mieux mais il ya aussi des lignes vers
boston par exemple qui sera notre
neuvième escale aux états unis
s'ajoutant toutes celles que nous avons
notamment miami et san francisco que
nous avons eu cette année et nous aurons
aussi deux provinces new york miss
direct ce qui est une nouveauté très
apprécié des démissions alors la
confiance il faut en parler parce que à
partir de 80 d'ouvrir une chose que les
gens gardent peut être pas c'est que
vous allez être en concurrence directe
avec toutes les autres compagnies
européennes avec ça sera la conséquence
de l'acte unique européen c'est à dire
92 c'est dans cinq ans mais je me
permets de dire je le regrette beaucoup
non pas que les esprits se fixer en ce
sens
air france a toujours vécu à 80% en
sommes pas en pleine concurrence par
quelle concurrence et des compagnies
américaines japonaises esterra le seul
secteur sur lequel nous étions en régime
dit de monopole bien qu'il n'ait jamais
été complet c'étaient les départements
d'outre-mer les 1,10 la réunion est ce
si effectivement a disparu depuis le 1er
juillet 86 puisque sur ce secteur là
aussi nous sommes en concurrence
donc c'est quelque chose à quoi nous
sommes très très habitué puisque nous
sommes la première compagnie à tokyo
c'est quand même pas rien d'être les
premiers à tokyo tant en fait qu'en pas
sachez d'ailleurs
et cette concurrence européenne nous
l'abordons sans aucun complexe parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on croit nous
estimons en europe être une compagnie
parmi les plus compétitives
sauf peut-être british airways mais
avoir largement la compétitivité de
grands aux autres on dit par exemple
air france a trop de personnel et qu'à
un coût de personnel trop important oui
seulement ce on dit cela comme ça sans
aucune base de chic fille j'ose dire
j'aimerais que l'on nous dise pourquoi
exactement
nous avons à l'heure actuelle à peu près
35 mille agents cette année où le trafic
est un peu inférieure
et nous avons moins de personnel que
nous n'avions prévu à peu près 4 500 490
exactement pour le personnel au sol 140
pour le servir navigant mais nous
n'estimons pas avoir trop de personnel
comme cela nous aimerions que ceux qui
disent ça ne justifie la plupart des
gens ignorent totalement qu'air france
et dans seulement deux compagnies
aériennes ils sont habitués à voir des
gens nous avons sept ou huit mille
ouvriers ils travaillent à l'entretien
nous sommes des succursales du groupe
atlas nous faisons le gros entretien de
bd boeing de dizaines de compagnies dans
le monde et on oublie toujours que
derrière la compagnie il y a de même que
par exemple lutter à user industrie nous
avons un air france industries
souhaiterait très puissant dernière
question monsieur marc selon est ce que
on voit l'évolution comme ça du trafic
aérien des grandes compagnies est ce que
air france ne sera pas obligé un jour de
se regrouper avec d'autres compagnies
européennes par exemple pour faire face
à la concurrence américaine cette fois
écouté il ne faut pas forcément
extrapoler et appliqué à l'europe des
solutions que nous avons vu se réaliser
cette année aux états unis
les etats unis sont les états unis nous
avons vu dans l'âme et 86 des
bouleversements absolument considérable
du transport est rien et à la fin de
cette année nous avons finalement cinq
grandes compagnies américaines qui à
force de fusion et de d'absorption fente
à elle seule 70% du trafic américain ce
qui est extraordinaire
alors les états européens ne sont pas
les états fédérés américains ils ont
derrière eux une longue histoire une
longue
ils ont la géographie aussi et c'est
tout de même pas demain que nous verrons
en être aimé prendre compagnon rennes
ceci dit il y a des accords de
coopération qui sont anciens qui existe
et que nous sommes tout à fait prêts à
développer et nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à rechercher avec les grandes
compagnies européennes que qu'elle nous
travaillons déjà ne pas des raisons
supplémentaires n'a pas de collaborer de
travailler ensemble
merci beaucoup monsieur marc selon merci
bien le sport